with Hollywood cranking out blockbuster
fare at a staggering rate and arthouse
sent him up fully coming into its own
the 90s were an exciting mixed bag at
the multiplex this combination of high
and low art carried over into video
stars to inspiring movie buffs to scour
shelves for both big-budget bonanzas and
obscure festival hits sadly those
searches often proved fruitless leaving
some of the decade's best films largely
unseen by the masses here are a few 90s
gems that are absolutely worthy of your
attention if you can track them down
that is Twin Peaks fire walk with me no
single show changed the landscape of
television in the 90s more than David
Lynch's supernatural murder mystery Twin
Peaks even after a game-changing first
season the show was unceremoniously
canceled in the midst of its wildly
uneven second season once the show ended
fans were delighted to find out that
Lynch still had Twin Peaks tales to tell
one of those tales that of Laura
Palmer's last week on earth got the big
screen treatment in Twin Peaks fire walk
with me free from the creative shackles
of television Lynch used the chance to
craft his most complex uncompromising
film to date sadly even the most devoted
of Twin Peaks fanbase had trouble
connecting with fire walk with me x'
arts the eccentricities the film proved
divisive amongst critics all but ignored
in its theatrical release and unfairly
doomed to a sort of purgatory in the
process for all of its quirks fire walk
with me stands as a creative high point
for Lynch breathlessly combining his
penchant for experimentation with his
trademarked biting commentary on the
American dream though the film has had
its defenders over the years and has
long held the title of cult classic it
still feels like not enough people have
actually seen it Chaplin before Robert
Downey jr. put Marvel on the map with
his now iconic turn in Iron Man Richard
Attenborough tapped him to star in his
Charlie Chaplin biopic appropriately
titled Chaplin lucky for Attenborough
and for film buffs everywhere townie jr.
turned in the finest performance of his
young career Landing RDJ his first Oscar
nomination but Attenborough's film is
more than just a showcase for Downey
juniors talent though it didn't fare
well with critics
who lamented it's 143 minute runtime and
overall lack of ingenuity Chaplin
remains a lovingly crafted in-depth look
behind the curtain of one of cinema's
greatest innovators the film is likely
to inspire viewers to go back and
explore Chaplin's own mind-blowing body
of work as well not to mention the
mostly terrific work Downey jr. has
delivered in the years since Chaplin's
release Red Rock West things have
certainly gotten away from Nicolas Cage
over the past decade or so but
throughout the 90s he was still deemed
an exciting supremely talented actor the
sort who could handle big-budget fare
but still Wow and micro budget Indies so
it came as no surprise that he'd follow
one of his biggest box-office hits
honeymoon in Vegas by starring as a
wayward drifter in John dolls Red Rock
West don't worry if you've never heard
of the brilliant neo-noir thriller the
film's been all but lost to history
since its release which is a shame
because Dolls nimble tale of small-town
swindling and mistaken identity is just
too slick today as it was back in 1996
it also happens to feature one of Kage's
most understated and affecting
performances with any luck the aging
actor might one day remember that
sometimes less actually is more
especially when bees are involved
dick back in 1999 a political satire
titled dick should have gotten a lot
more attention than it did sadly in the
almost two decades since the comedies
release the film still hasn't found its
audience with any luck however the
current political climate might change
that after all the girl power centric
story of political upheaval carries as
much weight today as it might have in
the year it was set the fact that dick
also features winning performances from
Kirsten Dunst Michelle Williams and Dan
hidaya as a brilliant Nixon caricature
makes it even more worthy of notice full
of insightful stoner styled comedy and
featuring a terrific supporting cast of
gifted comedians dick is a must-see that
too many moviegoers missed the first
time around Ghost Dog the way of the
samurai loosely adapted from jean-pierre
Melville's new wave classic lissome RI
1999's Ghost Dog the way of the samurai
seas notoriously experimental director
Jim Jarmusch is most accessible
whereas lists samurai saw its titular
silent assassin skulking around the back
alleys of Paris Forest Whitaker's
eponymous ghost dog calls the mean
streets of Brooklyn home Jarmusch
bolstered the film spiritual insights by
frequently quoting samurai philosophy
and backed his sword swinging killers
gritty urban journey with a head nodding
original score from wu-tang clan's RZA
combining ancient warrior wisdom with a
stylish hip-hop vibe Jarmusch spins an
engrossing and deeply satisfying story
of modern-day honor amongst thieves that
still resonates with film fanatics today
stir of echoes the ripple effect from
the sixth Ince's breakout success is
still being felt in Hollywood today in
other words it seems like every modern
horror film comes prepackaged with its
own flashy twist ending now imagine that
you released a haunting horror film rife
with unsettling imagery and yes a
shocking twist a mere months after the
sixth sense changed the horror game even
if your film was just as clever and
scary as M night Shyamalan masterpiece
it'd be virtually impossible to match
those
thence sized expectations such was the
case with David Capps stir of echoes
following the trials and tribulations of
a working-class dad who starts to
experience terrifying visions after a
hypnosis hiccup caps film is often just
as smart and creepy as the sixth it's at
times serve echoes even bests Shyamalan
flick on both fronts but it also
features a child who can speak to dead
people so yeah you can see the problem
with it being released after Haley Joel
Osment uttered those now iconic words
still stir of echoes is far from a cheap
knockoff and horror fans unfamiliar with
the unsung flick oh it to themselves to
give it a shot thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to